Speaker 1: . I have something really good
to show you.
Dan Goldman is a new congressman on the Democratic
side.
This guy is a major asset to the Democratic
Party.
He confronted Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
during this weaponisation committee.
Republicans, when they took control of the
House, created all of these bogus committees.
We're going to do a Twitter committee to look
into big tech.
We're going to do a weaponization of government
committee to look into the FBI and all these
different things.
Jim Jordan, during these hearings, has offhandedly
been mentioning that there are dozens of whistleblowers
who are who know the truth about what went
on.
Dan Goldman, who's an attorney.
Actually confronts Jim Jordan and says, Are
there notes about these whistleblowers?
When will you give us the information about
these whistleblowers and look at how quickly
and easily Jim Jordan is tangled up into a
rhetorical pretzel?
This is so devastating the way that Goldman
schools Jordan here is brutal.
And I don't know why Jordan would have expected
anything else from a former federal prosecutor,
an actual prosecutor.
Let's dive right into this.
This is gold.
Speaker 2: On providing that to them.
I.
Speaker 5: The point is, it wasn't special
so much.
It became the norm.
With that, the chair now ranking.
Speaker 2: It as a point of order.
There have been a lot of mention of information
and testimony that you all have received from
whistleblowers.
When are you planning on providing that to
the minority?
Speaker 5: You come in for the very first
deposition or any transcribed interview.
The whistleblower.
I was there when he testified on Tuesday.
Speaker 2: Okay, that's fine.
I assume I assume you'll turn those over.
But what about how you talk about dozens of
whistleblowers?
When are we going to get that information?
Speaker 1: Remember, dozens means at least
24.
You talk about at least two dozen.
Speaker 5: When that when they testify, when
we work with.
I'll work with the ranking member on that.
If you don't.
Speaker 2: Have any transcriptions of their
interviews.
Speaker 5: We have the first one and we have
the dozens who come and talk to our office.
Speaker 2: They talk to your office privately.
Speaker 5: Talk to Republican staff.
Right.
Speaker 2: And they're not transcribed.
No notes, no nothing.
Speaker 5: First one happened to.
I don't I'm not talking about the first one
time.
I happen to see the next one happens tomorrow.
The third one happens next Wednesday, and
we'll continue to do that.
Speaker 2: You just said dozens.
Are you do have notes from those.
Are they just talking to you to.
Speaker 1: Yourself at the rate at which Jordan
saying they're going to be talking to people
you're talking about a year before you hear
from dozens.
Speaker 2: Procurement isn't isn't that how
whistleblowers typically work?
Speaker 5: Well, it's how they're supposed
to work.
It's not how they worked in it in the impeachment
that Mr. Goldman was a part of.
Speaker 1: When it goes into add homonyms,
Mr..
Speaker 5: Schiff said he didn't have contact
with that whistleblower, but in fact.
Speaker 2: It worked greatly until Mr. Taylor
said would not allow.
Speaker 5: For doing it the way we're supposed
to do it.
Mr. GOLDMAN.
Speaker 2: No, you're supposed to turn it
over to the minority.
Speaker 5: When they when they when they come
and testify, you'll have access to the transcript.
Speaker 1: And understand what Jordan's.
So the point that Goldman is making is inquiring
as to whether these dozens of whistleblowers
really exist because they keep being mentioned
in passing.
And what Jordan wants to focus on is you'll
hear from them when they come and testify.
But of course.
Both sides have people on the committee.
Both sides get to ask witnesses questions
in order for the Democrats on the committee
to be ready to meaningfully inquire of these
supposedly dozens of whistleblowers.
They need information about them.
They don't even have names.
Understand that.
And then that'll be mentioned in a moment.
Jim Jordan keeps saying, well, you'll get
information when they testify.
And Goldman says, But where are the notes?
Where's the information so we can prepare?
The implication, of course, is these dozens
of whistleblowers simply don't exist.
Speaker 5: Everyone on the committee, well.
Speaker 2: You mean your staff is not going
to turn it over to our staff?
We're just in the dark.
Speaker 5: When the transcript is done, you
will get the transcript.
Speaker 2: I mean, of all the dozens of whistleblowers
you have already talked to that came to talk
to your.
Speaker 1: Staff, supposedly.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
What do you want me to turn over there.
Speaker 1: Jim?
Are the whistleblowers in the room with us
right now?
Can you see them, Hear their names.
Speaker 2: Notes?
Did anyone take notes?
Speaker 5: We'll be.
I'll be happy to talk with the ranking member
on how we handle that information.
Thank you all.
We will schedule each for a deposition.
Speaker 1: That is not what he's talking about
doing.
Speaker 5: That you didn't show up for the
first one.
You could have been there with that.
I didn't know about it.
The Chair Now recognizing that.
Speaker 1: Goldman's a really valuable asset
in this political climate, he is straightforward
in his approach, but he maintains a professional
demeanor.
He has extraordinary attention to detail.
He leaves no stone unturned in his lines of
inquiry.
And we all know the implication here, which
is there is no evidence that these dozens
of whistleblowers exist.
We're aware of one supposed whistleblower.
Remember also that the right has a history
over the last, let's call it, in the Trump
era, in the last six plus years, the right
has a history of presenting someone as a whistleblower
when they're not really blowing the whistle
about anything.
Like I could call myself a whistleblower.
But then if I show up and I basically say,
here's the terms of service from Twitter and
they were being followed, I'm not really blowing
the whistle on anything, right?
You can call me a whistleblower.
You can turn on bright lights and put makeup
on me and ask me questions and say I'm a hero
and put me on HANNITY or whatever.
But I'm not really blowing the whistle unless
I'm actually blowing the whistle.
And so do these 24 or 36.
I don't know how many dozens, Jim.
I don't know if Jim Jordan knows what the
word dozens mean, but.
If these dozens of whistleblowers exist is
is a real question.
And if people exist, who are going to be called
whistleblowers?
There's a real question as whether as to whether
they are blowing the whistle about anything.
So, Jim, Jordan is not the type of guy that
can go up against Dan Goldman.
Jim Jordan should be embarrassed in this way
at every single hearing because he is a joke
and it is humiliating.
We'll have the clips I played for you here
on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show and on our YouTube channel, Search
YouTube for David Pakman show.
You'll find it easily.